is released this week after watching the
movie last night I can highly recommend
that you go and see it it definitely
ranks up there as one of Christopher
Nolan's best and it cements his legacy
as a versatile director who can really
handle any subject matter but what
events inspired the movie I decided to
do a top six list of Dunkirk facts which
give an insight into exactly how
horrific the event was number six the
smallest boat to take part was the
Tamsin a 14-foot open top fishing boat
this tiny boat helped to save many lives
that day in showcases the bravery of
those who mandate the boat now resides
in the Imperial War Museum fact 5 the
evacuation began on May 27th just 8
thousand soldiers were rescued but over
the next eight days a total of three
hundred and thirty-eight thousand two
hundred and twenty-six Allied soldiers
were successfully brought across the
English Channel while under full attack
on all sides around 20,000 men were
picked up from the Dunkirk moles which
from the film you can see is a long
stone wooden jetty at the mouth of the
Corps soldiers had to wait patiently
while under attack from enemy aircraft
the rest of the men were evacuated from
the beaches often have it away hours and
shoulder deep water around 700 little
ships took part with civilians often at
the helm picking up soldiers from the
shallows they would then deliver the men
or larger ships or take them all the way
home some were amazed at the patience of
the troops you know what Alfred Baldwin
recalled you had the impression of
people standing waiting for a bus there
was no pushing no
shoving people just waited that's for
the Aria fought hard to come back the
bombs raining down on the men waiting on
the beaches flying a total of three and
a half thousand saw even losing a
hundred and forty five aircraft while I
look what lost a hundred and fifty six
factory more than two hundred ships and
boats were lost during the evacuation
with many tragedies on May 29th the
destroyer Wake Hall was torpedoed and
sank in fifteen seconds with the loss of
600 lives it is estimated that around
three and a half thousand British men
were killed at sea or on the beaches and
more than 1,000 on coke citizens in air
raids back - there were obviously a lot
of atrocities that went on during that
time so I'm gonna go more into those now
May 27 1970 while Norfolk regimen ran
out of ammunition and surrendered at the
village of Lee parody's they were shot
in cold blood on orders of the SS around
40,000 British troops never made it back
across the English Channel and became
POWs many of those ended up having to
endure forced marches into Germany and
served as slave labor for the Nazis but
a few of those left behind such as bill
lacy from Devon may dramatic escapes you
stole the French fishing boat and sailed
the back to England on his own Churchill
hailed Dunkirk as a miracle but also
warned relieved Britain's that the wars
were not won by evacuations he went on
to give one of his most famous speeches
to the House of Commons in which he
vowed that we shall fight them on the
beaches we shall fight them on the
landing grounds we shall fight them in
the fields and in the streets we shall
fight them in the Hills we shall never
surrender the phrase Dunkirk spirit has
since become part of the language used a
toast to people who pulled together in
time of adversity fact one the rescue
plan was called Operation dynamo it was
named for the dynamo room that produced
the electricity for the naval HQ
underneath dover castle the original
plan of operation dynamo car
only having 48 hours before the Germans
moved in and stopped the retreat they
believed that they would be able to
evacuate around 45,000 troops in that
timeframe luckily on the third day May
29th
the Germans halted their advance and
allowed the operation to continue all
the way till June 4th over 300 thousand
men were rescued from the beaches and
the Dunkirk Harbor the initial blame for
the German Army's halt was placed solely
on Adolf Hitler it was revealed after
the war that general GERD von run
Stern's Diaries had all of the Hulk
instead worried about the swampy terrain
effect on tanks and his supply line
Hitler agreed with his assessment the
inability for the German army to move on
the survivors of Dunkirk is noted by
many historians is one of the most
critical mistakes Hitler made so that's
my top 6 Dunkirk backs have you seen the
film what did you think about it comment
below let me know see you next time
[Music]